-I watched the first
couple of episodes of this.
It is right up my alley.
I really love it.
You play the defense attorney --
the real-life defense attorney
who defended the Menendezes.
-Indeed, I do, yes.
-Leslie Abramson.
-Yes.
-But you did not meet her
personally, you never
spoke to her, right?
-No, no, apparently she was
approached by the NBC people
and she was not interested
in partaking.
-Gotcha. But this was a trial
that was very much
on television.
But you also play her,
as we saw in the clip,
you sort of play
her private life.
Do you feel a bit of freedom,
not having met her, that you get
to make your own choices?
-You know, I hate to say that,
but a little bit.
Because the truth is nobody
knows what happened with her
alone with her husband.
I guess that´s
up for conjecture.
But nobody that I know
knows what happened.
And so there´s no way of knowing
beyond one´s imagination
what that was like.
So yeah, I guess it´s easier
than if she was there.
It was like,
"That never happened."
You know, so...
-This is better, yeah.
You got the freedom of choice.
The one thing, though,
that definitely happened,
and I want to know
whether you enjoyed this,
or you found this limiting.
The wig that you have
in this show
is really just one to remember.
-Then there´s the wig.
[ Laughter ]
-And that is -- I guess
that was hair in the ´90s.
That was -- she didn´t walk in
and everybody said,
"What´s going on
with your hair?"
That was just a thing
a lot of people were doing.
-Well, no. The truth is
that´s exactly what I wanted.
I wish I had seen this picture
when it was the ´90s
´cause I would have been
so frigging happy.
I tried -- all the perms I got,
how badly they turned out.
-What went wrong with your perm?
-Well, often my hair
wasn´t long enough.
You can´t get a perm
with short hair.
-Yeah, oh -- they didn´t
tell you before they did it?
-No, no.
But it´s what everybody wanted.
And she, Leslie Abramson,
was born with this hair.
-Oh, really?
-And she hated it,
from what I understand. It was
the bane of her existence.
-You guys, should do like,
a "Gift of the Magi"
where you trade hair somehow.
[ Light laughter ]
I don´t know what --
-Next year´s project.
-[ Laughing ]
Next year´s project.